[Music]
when you start cave exploration you're
jumping into an opening under earth and
nobody really nobody was in before
you're the first human in this area and
you look into a time window we are
talking millions of years actually what
you have right in front of you that is
this is a fantastic feeling
my name is uber hot and I'm a diving
instructor and I'm living here 26 years
in the Dominican Republic my specialty
is to explore caves when I started I was
not looking for caves I was looking for
some old Torino Indian stuff I found big
cave entrances and of course as a diving
instructor you are interested what's
going on here and this is when I started
actually to explore my first caves I was
a pioneer in cave exploration
the Dominican Republic has right now
more than 140 caves we are still
exploring and here in Baia Hebrew we
have a nice huge national park at this
National Park is like Swiss cheese and
has a huge amount of underwater caves
when I do this today of course you're
looking as a cave Explorer in a
completely different way maybe you find
a different passage or maybe you can
connect a whole bunch of caves you're
always looking really for small openings
to find new stuff diving in the open
ocean when you have a small problem
you're way out of the water is to going
up in a cave you have an overhead
environment you cannot go up when I go
in the ocean you have noises everywhere
you can listen to the boat engines you
can listen to noises underwater
when you go in a cave you will listen to
nothing just to your bubbles and this is
for me one of the most wonderful things
on earth no noises at all cave diving is
my passion and still after 20 years I
love it I love to teach people to do
cave diving in a safe way I'm 59 years
old so I need somebody behind me to do
the same stuff when I'm getting too old
it's good for me to see the young people
they are into this nice nice nice cave
exploration thing and very happy they
asking still the old guy how to do some
stuff
[Music]